si comme moi vous aimez les widgets et
que vous en mettez plein sur votre page
j'arrive à un moment où la mise en page
peut être pas terrible ça me saoule est
venu corriger ça avec mon nuage 5.20
vous pouvez venir les regrouper regardez
je vous montre vous prenez un de vos
widgets vous le faites glisser sur
l'autre et ils viennent tous se mettre
au même endroit alors il faut que ce
soit exactement le même format ici c'est
du 4 par an ça va très bien et ensuite
vous les avez vous n'avez plus qu'à
glisser comme ça le widget de batterie
on va retrouver le widget je sais plus
quoi l'autre widget de Google Chrome la
recherche Google LinkedIn bref tout ça
très pratique très malin d'avoir tout
ici au même endroit qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de cette astuce est-ce qu'elle
vous intéresse est-ce que ça pourra vous
servir à l'avenir marquer moi ça bien
évidemment dans les commentaires